les maisons on voit d'ailleurs la
majorité n'est pas amis des bêtes ils
ont dû au consultant mise avec des
dirigeants du m23 au trot monté de la
mer puisque à huy ah oui parce que
l'amérique est vraiment appuyé sur les
maisons c'est comme vieux souvenirs 2000
la rd102 2010 j'ai dû mettre des pierres
duc est arrivé pour protéger toute la
côte mal à la saveur d'antan jouées ont
commencé à me défaire depuis la barre
pour descendre ces maisons là mais vu
les aider ils veulent pas qu'on prenne
les pieds à la radio comme ça donc je
solidarité et je fais ça gratuitement je
suis pas payé je suis je de monnières ya
lu sur les gens qui sont solides et tu
me donnes de l'argent pour le gazole à
la machine et puis je continue à faire à
bois
la chance des peines ya jean collègues à
moi qui scanne peu loupé de la région
monsieur parent ami il est de ces
pierres c'est lui qui m'envoient des
pierres et puis on fait ça pour la
population ici bonjour mr machine ici
puis le reste le web avec ses camions
motos